when Tricia Cowen and her family
returned to Hong Kong in April they were
put in mandatory quarantine for 14 days
they were also required to wear this
electronic wristband that alerted
authorities if they breached their
quarantine regulations and left their
apartment around side it's didn't I
didn't even think about it I just think
that this had to be done I mean it's
people need to be tracked and no one
wants it spread further we all want it
to be over as quickly as possible so
that that just didn't bother me tracking
technology developed in Hong Kong uses a
Wi-Fi network to detect if the user
changes location but the company says
the only data shared with the government
is movement not personal information
technology we have a lot of option like
face recognition and speech recognition
but using this way the government will
be alert when the user not their home
but at the same time it had the way
about mobile apps and digital
surveillance are being used by many
governments in Asia to track the spread
of the coronavirus China uses a color
based QR code to monitor people's
movements and health in South Korea
overseas travelers who don't download a
government app refused entry I think
it's a key part of infection control in
Asia especially using this technology to
track down these people and putting them
into quarantine so it is probably one of
the most important reasons why we are
doing better than other parts of the
world but critics say some
government-mandated apps can also access
a user's personal data and be used as a
surveillance tool it's a real fear that
this data will end up in the hands of
governments some of the apps look for
people's location data they use access
to their cell phone records their call
records even their contacts and in some
cases the camera and all that
information together can reveal very
sensitive insights into people's lives
two of the world's biggest tech giant's
at Google and Apple plan to embed new
features in their devices using contact
tracing technology
both say the tool will be removed once
the pandemic ends but critics say it
could lead to ongoing surveillance with
governments using the data for other
purposes technology may be playing a
critical role in containing the pandemic
but human rights groups warn it may also
normalize surveillance in the future
once this outbreak is under control
Sarah Clark al Jazeera Hong Kong no
Newcastle University is linear Edwards
is a professor of law focusing on
innovation and society she says newer
versions of the apps are addressing
security concerns there was kind of a
first generation of apps which did come
out of Asia such as the China Alibaba
it's my q on traffic lights at the Hong
Kong app which were fairly grossly
privacy invasive and perhaps justifiable
within the culture at that time but
we're not really acceptable to Europe
and to some Asian countries and other
countries so there's been this second
wave of Bluetooth apps which really only
detects proximity rather than your
geolocation but within that class we're
now having a very heated debate about
centralized against decentralized apps
so basically you can keep all the data
that's collected on the respective bones
of the people involved and that's what
the Google Apple API that's been best
about to be rolled out supports and that
is very very pretty
deserving on the other hand a number of
countries notably the UK France and
Australia so far I've chosen to go for a
more centralized model where data is
passed back to more state central
servers like the NHS and that can be
argued to be something they want because
they want to collect more data they want
to be able to amend that data more
quickly and more precisely but it is
less privacy protected so this is where
the debate is revolving around what's
the best trade-off and indeed doesn't
need to be a trade-off because some
people in some of the consortium claim
that you can get everything you want and
still be maximally privacy supportive